poi mettiamo elementi dentro c'è sta
facendo le bollicine nutrition i castori
oggi a grandissima richiesta e torneremo
a fare un sacco di scherzi aschieri
teacher nome maestra cattiva da rovinare
un suo appuntamento romantico sarà
troppo divertente vediamo l'ora già
l'ultimo video in cui facciamo gli
scherzi artificieri è piaciuto
tantissimo siete impazziti
quindi eccovi qua un altro video
lasciato un bel mi piace se volete che
continuiamo a fare gli scherzi ascheri
teacher mi raccomando stato il più bel
mi piace e se non avete visto l'ultimo
video in cui con merlino e costruiamo un
parco giochi nel giardino ci siamo
divertiti un sacco elevato le rose of
war divertente abbiamo fatto per
parcheggio con un percorso per merlino
andate a vederlo dopo questo video e ora
mettetevi comodi prende tempo
iniziamo subito ti vuole fare un party
con lo show ma noi andremo ha rovinato
allora mi tradì cosa ha detto ha detto
non vedo l'ora che arrivi il mio
fidanzato così lo sorpresero con questo
party con lo champagne e sia detto che
noi studenti i suoi studenti perché noi
siamo gli studenti di questa maestra
cattiva scheri teacher abbiamo pagato
noi per questo champagne
non è giusto comunque noi di loro vi
diremo per benino questo marty allora
vedo che evitare festeggiate ansia lo
scotch e poi cos'altro prendiamo
dobbiamo rovinarvi di questo parto così
impara tramonto ci chiama sempre con dei
nomi bruttissimi infatti non è giusto
rimarrà impressionato e tenete alta
dalle parti che gli organizzeremo noi
faremo una bella sorpresa se vuoi fare
qual è il tuo piano le faremo uno
scherzo alla circolazione si trovano un
bar di auto visto si no forse mi ha
visto mi ha messa tutta in altre
relazioni e si va a prenderla
dunque servono per avere più tempo siamo
già in cucina in cucina
la giustizia quando un apribottiglie per
fare lo scherzo
cosa dire la stampa ne ho mai lasciato
ma perché sono scomparse termine la
cassetta vuoi mettere qualcosa di troppo
mai avevo già fatto uno scherzo io vedo
la renault vista sarah nel suo diario
come reagirà te che mi raccomando anche
voi guardate sempre le camere di
sicurezza per vedere dove sta andando
scarichi crf attitude nostre non milioni
sta qui ho visto allo stesso divano ma
forse perché tutti uguali per questo
evento
le caramelle se dobbiamo provare a
scappare senza che lei arrivi subito qui
e quindi metti lamentato nello champagne
planano idea geniale no anche noi si è
distratta sul fortuna avete visto nella
camera ci vedevamo l'idea dieta ora
dobbiamo mettere le caramelle non e
suppongo che lei ha saputo anche come
indosso per il parmense
chiedete instaurando un vestito
riconosciamo la bottiglia di champagne
da allora utilizziamo la forbice per
togliere
siamo questo per togliere l'italia con
api noi mettiamo elementi dentro c'è sta
facendo le bollicine e di questo devo
rimettere primo il tappo se no come
quelli che stiamo la carta così non se
ne accorge ma insegnare perché poi
sigilliamo tutto col nastro proprio
della casa sta già arrivando allo
champagne bar duca prossimi terzo vero
che visti gli piazza il suo tacchino
dobbiamo bruciare allora
e non era chiuso con stile coincide con
la sua personalità rovinare il pranzo di
we the teacher bruciando il tacchino in
forno anche questo scherzo lo fa vitale
che è super bravi perché dice reja me
invece prende subito vi viene l'ansia il
suo scappare mi perdo nelle di civili in
quanto esiste per l'anglo giuste voi
riusciti a giocare bene asteriti cielo
se anche a voi vi prende se quel
prossimo provo a farlo io anche se so
che andrà malissimo
allora vitale ha già preso la benzina
basket dove sto pensando l'abusivo deve
essere ben cotto quindi forse il caso di
crisi
beh dell'ista visto che così cattiva se
avete scritto nei commenti dello scorso
video che è sotto il tappeto c'è la
chiara ea me per attrarre infatti grazie
per tutti i consigli che si scrive the
quindi dopo proviamo a vedere se no mi
sta leggendo un libro bene gli spazi
noi abbiamo allora sono attento ho messo
10 mila trappole che va a rimanere
nascosto perché questo considerevole
parte
in cucina giusto in tempo
ok non proviamo
stiamo molto attenti ad esso ma com'è
che riesce a passare attraverso la porta
ai muri tende nell'istituto real resta
bloccato l'estensore così o lo può
utilizzare nei cattivi candelotti di
dinamite esistenti ove si è così almeno
la l'estintore non funzionerà lei
proverà ad utilizzare il il secchio
pieno d'acqua
la benzina non messo in questo
contenitore ha così lo posso mettere
direttamente sul suo tacchino vediamo
chi dice di sapere che se gli scappa
scappa scappa scappa
frattini non vedo l'ora di vedere la
reazione è un tacchino e sta correndo
prendere le scritture gli scrittori non
funziona ovviamente perché abbiamo messo
adesso va a prendere l'acqua
il facchino ormai scotto prossimo
scherzo allora tutto quello che vuole
misti e controllare le persone quindi
che abbiamo le carte in tavola
quindi vuol dire che noi la
controlleremo la ipnotizzato avete
capito
in pratica ha detto che le vuole
prendere il controllo di prato e quindi
ho messo un amuleto vedete ce l'ha
ancora in testa vede telecamere per
controllare il suo fidanzato
gli ho detto vai a prepararmi qualcosa
da bere
quindi noi dobbiamo trovare un modo per
ipnotizzare mi di liberare francis a
inchieste palestra quindi devo trovare
il fidanzato ipnotizza stessi dove farli
in cucina guardamiglio brulica
all'angolo mentre passava lei si è visto
la camera delle torture di visti vabbè
prendiamo la nostra sta facendo su e giù
dalle scale
ma perché no non se n'era accorta
smettere di inseguire il pari no no
dovevi scappare 29 vinta dalle perché io
non è mai ripresa il calcolo ai preti
l'amuleto e colombe lui non sia così la
mano di noi tutti e tira talamonti
lavoro gol non l'ho fatto apposta scusa
a lei stessa non c'era andando su lei
qui c'è un lucchetto
proviamo entrare vediamo cosa nascosto
si passa di qua quindi dobbiamo è stato
ancora lui ma lui non è più uno fissato
quindi attenta passato faceva il bagno
si vedono solo i capelli ma basta
[Musica]
guardare e così di nuovo qua speriamo
questa volta che no non è più in bagno
lì c'è qualcosa di molto inquietante
perché c'era il suo riflesso nello
specchio bene mangiando specchio e non
sappiamo se lo è adesso però sto tenendo
qui sicura ma figlio che ti nascondi
tutto
[Musica]
no lì si è accorto di prezzi ha detto
c'è qualcosa che non va come mai sta
dormendo
quindi dobbiamo ricominciare essere
ok a me teramo letto può prendere il
pallone ok bravissimo re scappa scappa
ma su che cosa si è fatto però che anzi
è appena uscita nello scantinato che si
sta da questa data che al primo che non
si accorge subito di franz incoraggiato
lo liberiamo come fate a richiudere un
gatto qua quindi miti noleggiano il
gatto così li diventa un gatto così
viene comandata dal gatto vediamo o devo
scappare un re stalla
[Musica]
allora dice diamo un altro significato
alla parola pop art in pratica che cos'è
la aspetta vediamo prima ora lasciamolo
dire il piuss che riti cerrato un calcio
al gatto come si permette non si può ora
glielo facciamo pagare e poi ha detto
che in pratica la popstar è una torta ha
detto che l'ha fatta il suo fidanzato mi
ha mandato la foto vice di rovinare
l'appuntamento romantico di mister non
vedo l'ora di rovinarlo
che cosa prendo però non lo so quasi
sotto il fango guardi devo trovare
qualcosa da mentre per essere anche
parlangeli a forma di cuore mentre 60 e
palloncini e posso prendere un
palloncino guardate per metterlo alla
porta visto che hanno la stessa forma
no non me lo può mettere nell'alto volta
quindi parte deve per qualcos'altro
[Musica]
sporche e rop roma vitale che è
sicuramente significa venire se questi
camera di lecce noi facendo i servi
quanti antipatica che la dobbiamo far
pagare a se non si trattano così gli
animali b e sta andando proprio ego jane
ha ora 9 facciamoci un giro sta curando
la tv ma volevano almeno sarà un po
impegnata da iniziati chiamò per casa da
metterle dentro la torta o nel
palloncino facciamo uno slide
con l'accordo degli facciamo lo slime
arriva scappiamo aspettiamo però di non
trovarmelo davanti ma quell istante a
questo enorme fucile dalla finestra
no io mi sono fatto male però sappiamo
che si poteva vestire dalla fine lei
rimasta lì bloccata su dire che sta
accendendo noti avviso io e scende le
scale che vediamo la camera di sicurezza
mai visto su un passato libro si è visto
mentre passavo roma nei minuti accorta
allora cosa possiamo prendere altro
vediamo in frigo che c'è cos'è questo
una torta la crema al cioccolato
interessante se ci crediamo
proviamo anche noi abbiamo più che
questo suono che mi ferì vediamo se c'è
un altro
per la torta marmellata aggiungerà la
sorella anche lei e di fronte al camino
spento che si riscalda allora cominciamo
con la colla innanzitutto sbrigati
perché vista che utilizziamo il
palloncino che a forma di torta fermo
per la terna si è fermata maledizione
avevamo quanto è finito lo sterzo questo
quando gen
no non mi tirate
se ne accorgerà no forse non sono
affatto
[Musica]
abbiamo fallito ma ora riproviamo e
facciamo in modo che puzza ci risiamo
abbiamo rifatto tutto daccapo ora uniti
e cina è un bagno e quindi dobbiamo
subito andare sul tavolo e preparare lo
scherzetto prima che lei e rivive se poi
scappiamo dalla cucina mi sarà ok pronti
perché diciamo qualcosa poi palloncino
in siria o il cioccolato ricoperto di
cioccolato quindi sta creando la torta
con il palloncino e adesso scagliate la
torta di mele vero se non se ne accorse
succedono una brava bravissima questa ce
la mangiamo
ok ok per far scappare scappo
velocissimi sono fatto male questo
scappare rispettato sì sì sì sì
scappa scappa ecco la lista citiamo
video questo appuntamento romantico
corvino sta per arrivare dopo arriva all
[Musica]
siamo quasi diventato esco così ecco
perché lui aveva fatto la torta di litio
e quindi se l'è presa con lui esistono
due figli da great britain a faccia
nella verità di share
scriveteci nei commenti qual è stato il
vostro scherzo reperita secondo me forse
quest'ultimo vela colloredo del cazzo è
stato un bel mi piace se volete vedere
altri scherzi scheri teaser e ora andate
a vedere il video scopriamo il
parcheggio in cover lino prolasso quota
troppo divertente e noi ci vediamo al
prossimo minio ciao